alright here's a white right here we'll
close it out with one king under sting
it and it's got like a supplementary
video he sent in with it it's my boy
Robbie from barstool what's up guys I
hope you're doing well it's Robbie from
barstool and I got a king intersting it
for you your boy Tom Segura has been
going off on professional wrestling fans
wrestlers themselves and he just put out
a press conference as mystic Rick I
don't have you've seen this I don't know
King under sting of forming Gang Gang
buzz-buzz we Canyon sting at Todd's I've
got Tom and his antics with the dodo ve
or we King astein Pro Wrestling in
general I think Tom's antics and his
character mystic Ric I've never seen I
know this for me off you see this I'm
pissed you off yeah let's watch this no
I was I meant that they're stupid
they're all beneath me you know they're
losers they want to come you know maybe
clean up my toilet or whatever they're
doing it just give a little taste of the
mystique hey Rick you're so strong if
you could even withstand the ankle lock
oh it's true
it's damn true mission accomplished this
is my parent solstice you know we always
enter the ring together
anybody wants to get the turkey slicer
come come at me man mystic Rick you are
never down for the count
oh yes the best there was and the best
ever will be just keep those jeans high
in it I wear today you are thank you
[ __ ] rather Mike in his heart is shut up
my showing Calgary in all sweats Oh
everything a heart attack is because his
heart is filtering gin
that's why and I love him too and I say
that I'll heart
should we keep rolling yo dude or let's
keep rolling mash it's making me sick
it's fake
why can't I win a fake fight sign me up
let's rehearse I'll whoop your fake ass
is the strongest and the best and he
throws it down in the bedroom the best
my main man mr. champ and I'm the one to
take know keep feather it brother and
congrats on your you exotics hot one
classy Christmas party Cody
Sammy Webber Vera the Spanish sizzle
steak you can get you appreciate it in
your language - appearance you know F
Houston pinata
marika reporting getting cancer when the
hearing room de minimis llamo me
understand anyone of you fake-ass
athletes can get this fake punch thrown
at your fake face
mr. Greek in espanol no more questions
I'm late I have a caviar tasting in my
McLaren
y'all suck my dick
[Laughter]
damn his hat says got cup you know I
just think it's messed up I just think
you know they obviously used these older
guys Ric Flair and these guys on cam he
honeydicked he totally did man dude
whisper key slicer dude Ric Flair looks
like he's full of cheese everyone hurt
hey Ric Flair definite looks like he has
got a strong case of gray areas cleared
up more Flair than Rick dude Bret the
Hitman Hart came by showing Calgary and
you know he's good to do this Hulk Hogan
bit and the owner of the Yuk Yuk's just
a man we got we got Rick we got Bret the
Hitman Hart company's basically you know
he's like God he's our staple here in
Calgary and he's wov guy so cut the [ __ ]
with the Hulk Hogan bit tonight
Yeah right did it I think he came back
backstage and all sweat so I was like oh
I'm glad you dressed up but he came in
he came back and he wouldn't look at me
he just stared at my brother BAM he just
stared literally through my brother's
soul and told old-school stories Wow
it was great dude that's awesome man hey
man are you super friendly dude he was a
legend bro dude his brother Marty
Jannetty Owen Owen haulin our old fell
off the top he's gonna do a stunt and
fell off the top and died I remember
when that happened crazy huh that's
pretty sad dude Amy's Canadian huh
mm-hmm Calgary Calgary Alberta this
whole family is like like a huge they're
basically like the [ __ ] JJ Watts
really yeah Wow Russians say the
Mannings
he's been through it all man but yeah I
just I say what did he say King under
sting it man yeah mr. Creek I sting it
damn I think mister mister mister Rick
what's his name
misuk you dick
it's not Richard I can't I'm with you I
want to ride with you here but I'm with
it with the fake sports sport what they
do is sow fake Brendon it's pretty fake
Wow and it's challenging it's tough but
so is Mickey on ice yeah yeah you know
the right we'll see what the Rat King
says yeah I think I can use em something
to say about this writing you coming hot
off the top rope oh but make sure you
rehearse it before it's the only way to
come in brother ha he wants that [ __ ]
Swiss wheelchair I'll give it to him
yeah yeah all them gears up and [ __ ]
come off that I know how to do it dude
[Laughter]
I'm not taking it from some man used to
oil in it to go to UFC their brain and
getting Pam spray on with garlic garlic
you got the wrong one out of my bag Oh
like steak dude get your get your fake
tan spray on oil that [ __ ] are you
well let go cheese covered body up come
up that top rope ha ha if you wanna you
get some of it too boy all right maybe a
240 son maybe a 2000 fat Rick or
whatever that guy's whatever that
frickin mr. group yeah whatever that
[ __ ] Walmart damn crossdresser
whatever his name is that frickin salt
intake victim I feel like Nick are your
WWE fella I watched a lot in the 90s
that kind of stomper - I'll tell you the
90s and then I grew up you know I did
not know no adults were gonna be
watching it when I was 13 I was like you
grow out of this you got to stop but
some adults just keep on powering
through it it's real to me
[Music]
the king
[Music]